all right now in this video we're going
to talk about the thyroid gland it's
very rare to have a primary thyroid
problem maybe if you live in an area
where there's no iodine you can have a
thyroid problem but it's just really
rare so what you want to do if you have
thyroid symptoms which are hair loss dry
hair slow metabolism loss of eyebrows
right here weight gain all over the
place and abnormal thyroid hormones and
blood tests then you're going to look at
three different areas for the root cause
and you're going to work on whatever
shows up on that and then recheck your
thyroid and you're going to find your
thyroid will start to come back now
there's a case that you may have had
your thyroid removed or partially
removed then you're going to need to
take the medication but still it's
necessary for you to isolate what the
trigger was for the original problem in
the first place but let's just talk
about the the primary causes of thyroid
issue number one the liver and
gallbladder if 80% thyroid is converted
from t4 to t3 through the liver and the
gallbladder
so t4 t3 represents the number of iodine
molecules so t4 is inactive thyroid so
it really doesn't do anything if it's in
the blood that would be something like
synthroid the medication but then the
liver converts it takes iodine off and
it becomes a t3 and that's an active
form and that's where it does the work
so if you're taking thyroid hormones
but you're still tired you're still cold
be cold hands etc it just could be this
not converting so if you have any number
of liver symptoms bloating burping
belching right shoulder pain headaches
any of the fats above vitamin
deficiencies in the other video that we
talked about it could mean that the
gallbladders you need need some
gallbladder formula support to be able
to give you the bile support to convert
this and then let's see if your thyroid
kind of comes back to normal alright so
that's number one number two would be of
the adrenals adrenals can cause
the thyroid to not work but the way it does
it creates an autoimmune disease now
what is it autoimmune it means that your
own thyroid is attacking itself all
autoimmune diseases are triggered by
some stress if you ask anyone with
autoimmune ask him when it occurred and
exactly what happened
it was after some stress event could be
pregnancy could be divorce or whatever
so that stress shocks the different
parts of the body and you created all
the Lamia so then the the there's two
main autoimmune diseases for thyroid
there's one where the thyroid hormones
are too high it's hyper thyroid that's
called Graves and then there's a hypo
which is too low and that's called
Hashimoto's but both of them are
triggered by stress so the only thing
you want to do for that if the person
either has a thyroid left or you have
your thyroid or don't have your thyroid
is you want to do this like how do you
get rid of autoimmune there's a
something you can take it's called a PMG it's called a proto morphogen don't
worry about the name it's basically it
said it's kind of an extract from
thyroid gland from the DNA and you take
it orally you take one of these and the
remedy you take is called thyrotropin PM
g you can get it from standard process i
think an even buy it online because
they're selling it all over the place
you can probably have an amazon.com
thyrotropin so if it's autoimmune you
take one thyroid thyrotropin PMG before
you go to bed what happens it goes into
your body in your stomach and there's
all these lymph nodes in your stomach
and these antibodies that are attacking
and destroying your own thyroid will go
goes right to your stomach instead of
your thyroid it acts as a decoy so
therefore you can then deplete all the
store antibodies that are
attacking your body over to this decoy
in your stomach and eventually have the
thyroid actually heal up so that's one
remedy for autoimmune when it's hyper or
hypo even if you had it removed you
still want to do it because there's
antibodies sitting there that's just one
thing so and then support the adrenals
do things for the adrenal support that's
in a different video but I just want you
to think with the information not be
robotic about it okay so that's number
one number one you do the gall bladder
formula number two you do that retro fan
PMG and adrenal support and eliminate
the trigger and stress in three is the
overactive ovary the ovaries produce a
lot of estrogen if the person is
estrogen dominant they're pumping out
too much estrogen and you can tell that
by their periods the periods are crazy
heavy bleeding cramping irregular
infertility PMS or they had a pregnancy
or they have a fibroid all these things
all that extra estrogen
can act as a A mimicrer of the thyroid
hormone so estrogen can block the
receptors for the thyroid hormone so
they can fit in there like a lock and a
key and lock up the gland so the thyroid
can't go in the receptors to do its job
so estrogen inhibits the thyroid
function over time it blocks it it
prevents it from working so increase
estrogen decrease thyroid function okay
so if that's the case so what you're
doing is you're scanning your body and
figure on add web Mar digestive issues
do I have on immune do I have a period
issue okay let's say it's a period issue
then we want to support the ovary with
something called ovary support formula
and cruciferous food because cruciferous
is anti Astra genic and that will clean
all this up so I know some people say
don't take reciprocal because it pulls
out iodine well I put sea kelp back into
that product so there won't be any loss
of
so it's real simple we find out which it
is and then we work on that primary area
so your thyroid can come up but we're
still not done yet
we're going to apply acupressure and so
in the next part I'm going to show you
two acupressure for the thyroid and it's
very powerful so that way you've
exhausted all the different techniques
to improve the thyroid function this I'm
trying to make this as simple as
possible now you might have oh my gosh I
have all these problems I have a liver
problem and all that problem between the
problem of estrogen then you might need
to work on each one of them in some of
the other videos I'm going to kind of
help you show you what causes what so
you can think with it but again I'm
trying to take a complex subject and
make it very simple I hope this gave you
some basics on what to do and just look
at one two three and see what would
affect the thyroid